côté jeunes thuan non pas oui et toi tu
as quel âge moi j'ai l'âge qu'avait
rimbaud n'avoir on décrire le bateau
ivre ah bon alors tu as tu as nos
banques
falah mais c'est bien toi t'as quel âge
bon bah ouais pareil en plein dedans
aussi
ouais t'es un peu fatigué de tamba wells
aussi tu as l'air fatigué je vois tu as
vu les serbes que tu fais non mais ça
c'est parce que hier avant de me coucher
je j'ai fait un petit peu de lecture
j'ai relu les rougon-macquart 20 volumes
verrez pas lui déjà si si si si je les
avais déjà lu mais là c'était la
traduction rust away et je connaissais
pas le russe ilia aigles avaient fermé
fait drôle mais en fait j'ai appris hier
soir les hôtes moment qu'est ce qui fait
au bois en ce moment je continue mes
études à la sorbonne
ben oui y'a la sorbonne oui c'est bien
aux battues c'est donner des cours
devant 300 élèves c'est pas évident
même quand on est surdoué way puis quand
ta maman vient de chercher à la fin des
courses et la honte à vous enfin je lui
donne la main quand même oui c'est dur
d'être surdoué comme vous dites oui tu
mets toi on s'est rendu compte quand que
tu étais surdoué
ah ben moi c'est à la naissance - ah bon
ouais les chicons mais j'étais
prématurée ah bon alors on m'a mis dans
une couveuse oui à la couveuse est tombé
en panne
maman mais alors je ferai pareil
partout la bad et toi toi comment ils
vont s'éclater sans doute comme moi
c'est quand j'ai fait la visite avec les
psychologues away with chez les têtes
oui j'ai fait les tests des bennes
demain il a tapé une dépression nerveuse
voilà et puis les deux autres ils se
sont recyclés garde des moutons en
ardèche assez dur mon passage c'est
parce que moi je suis un cadre est
troublant web et je suis pas un
troublant aussi un donc je suis encore
très troublant plus troublant que toi je
suis plus troublant que toi mais je suis
plus trop blanc que toi moi marabout
bout de ficelle salut droid idéologie
gymnastes office fiche de ligne line
renaud perdu ah oui une connerie à la
télé grave mais ça c'est parce que tu
regarde la télévision
bon allez maintenant c'est terminé mais
faussetés manette wii pour le père noël
mais dis donc tu crois qu'on est pas un
petit peu en retard là pour le père noël
pourquoi tu fais on est déjà en avance
sur notre alors bravo les moyennes
qu'est-ce que tu as comme en des doigts
pour le père noël alors moi j'ai
commandé une panoplie de zorro panoplie
de zorro
oui the rockies ont dit ah bon et bien
et toi et ben ouais j'ai commandé un un
microscope à rayons laser pour l'étude
des mouvements sinusoïdaux en milieu
aquatique
eh bien oui oui mais j'ai pris aussi un
nounours en peluche
oui bah pourquoi bat pour rassurer mes
parents parce qu'ils s'inquiètent pour
avoir